and so I wanted to start today's lecture
by continuing what we were talking about
in the last lecture so I'm just gonna
hide this real quick and so we are
talking about the fruit fly and the
white gene and the white mutant which
results in white eyed flies and we
talked about how if you take females
that have red eyes and cross them to
males the white-eyed male then a hundred
percent of the progeny has red eyes in
the f1 generation and so I asked you
guys is would you get the same result if
you did the reciprocal cross okay
so what if we took white eyed females
and mated them to red eyed males so what
about this actually I'm gonna move this
over to over here so that maybe it's
more visible so what if we have white
eyed females and cross this to red eyed
males so let's unpack this sort of a
little bit at a time so what's the
genotype of these white eyed fina
females here miles
uh-huh yes okay so miles is exactly
right so the dominant phenotype is red
eyes because it's the gene encodes for
an enzyme that's important for the
production of the red pigment and so X
lowercase a here would be a recessive
mutant that lacks this that lacks the
pigment okay and because it's a
recessive allele because only you need
only one copy of this gene to produce
the pigment so the recessive allele
results in the white phenotype therefore
this has to be homozygous recessive okay
how about this red eyed now yeah worry
[Music]
yes so this would be this phenotype
right where capital a is the the gene
that produces as a normal functioning
gene that produces the pigment okay
so then in your f1 here what are you
gonna see something similar to this or
something different different great who
said different Javier do you want to
propose what you might see
[Music]
exactly so the mouths are gonna get the
Y from the father and they're gonna get
1x from their mother so all the males
are gonna be of this genotype here
which means they're gonna have what
color I Xavier is exactly right that
means they're gonna have white eyes
right so all the males will have white
eyes and what about the females what's
that yeah so Ori is saying the males are
gonna get red eyes right because they're
gay or the females are gonna have red
eyes because they're gonna get the X
chromosome from their father which has
the dominant gene that produces the red
pigment right so all the females are
gonna be heterozygous but have a
functional copy of this gene so all of
the females will have red eyes okay does
everyone see how now how would this
compare with Mendel's crosses and like
pea color would there be a difference in
Mendel's cross crosses if you switch the
male versus the female if these were
autosomal traits or is shaking his head
no and he's right right in that case it
doesn't matter you can do the reciprocal
crosses you get the same result but
because this is sick sex linked what
which one is the male and which is the
female is relevant okay and this
actually relates to something that I we
just saw on the MIT news that I've just
got this email this morning but it came
out I think yesterday which is that
biology related research in the
mechanical engineering department
specifically the chem lab they've been
able to design a 3d sort of model for
ALS disease which is also known as Lou
Gehrig's disease and so what they've
done in the chem lab is to take
cells from either patients that have ALS
or from normal individuals and they coax
these cells to become neurons here
you're seeing a neuron in blue and green
here and you see this the neurites
extend from this neuron and they have a
model where this neuron can then synapse
with a muscle and so they're using this
3d sort of tissue model to model ALS and
to look for drugs that might affect ALS
potentially curing ALS okay and so last
night I started reading about ALS and
was pleased to find that there's
actually a very there's a very rare
x-linked dominant form of the disease
that can be passed on from generation to
generation
and the inheritance pattern of this
x-linked dominant version of ALS would
have an inheritance pattern that's
similar to what we observe for the white
mutant in the fruit fly right whereas if
you have an affected father that's and
this is a dominant mutant on the X
chromosome then all of his daughter's
will get that X chromosome and be
affected whereas the sons will all be
unaffected however if you have the
reciprocal situation where you have an
affected mother and an unaffected father
then the sons and daughters get the
disease randomly okay so this is a sort
of form of inheritance which is relevant
if you're considering human disease and
some forms of it most versions of ALS
while are sporadic but the inherited
forms are usually autosomal dominant so
this is a rare case here but I thought
it was interesting in that it's relevant
to what we've been talking about okay so
now just to recap here I'll throw this
up so everything's up
so in the last lecture we talked about
Mendelian inheritance and we talked
about when you take two parents that
differ and two traits and you perform a
cross you get a hybrid individual that
is heterozygous for both genes and now
this is the f1 individual let's say we
want to know what types of gametes this
f1 individual individual produces we can
form we can perform a type of a cross
known as a test cross where we cross
this individual to another individual
that is homozygous recessive for both
these genes which means that you know
exactly which alleles are coming from
this parent and they're both recessive
so you can see whether or not the gamete
produced by this individual has either
the dominant or the recessive allele
okay so this up
okay so now we can consider the
different types of progeny that results
from this test cross and some will have
the two dominant alleles from this
parent and will therefore be
heterozygous for the a and B gene and it
would exhibit the dominant a and B
phenotype and I think that is what I'm
showing here so if the chromosomes
during meiosis one align like this then
the two dominant alleles segregate
together and you get a B gametes and on
the you also reciprocally get these
lowercase a and B gametes as well so
that's the other class here so you can
get these two these two classes of
progeny and the phenotypes of these two
classes will be resemble the parents
right so these are known as parental
gametes so these are the parentals okay
but you know because Mendel showed that
if you have genes and their alleles on
separate chromosomes they can assort
independently of each other
so an alternative alternative an
alternative Li likely scenario is that
the chromosomes aligned like this where
now the dominant allele of B is on the
other side of the spindle and therefore
these chromosomes are going to segregate
like this during the first meiotic
division and that gives rise to gametes
that have a different combination of
alleles than the parents okay so you
have some look like this
so each of these would be different
classes of progeny and you have one last
class that would look like this okay and
so neither of these look like the
original parents and so they're known as
non parental and so if these two genes
are behaving according to Mendel's
second law where there's independent
assortment if you have independent
assortment what's going to be the ratio
of parental to non parental yeah Rachel
yeah Rachel says one to one and I think
a number of others also said one to one
so you have 50% parental 50% non
parental right because it's equally
likely to get either of those alignments
of the homologous chromosomes during
meiosis one okay so now I'm gonna
basically break the rules I just
explained to you in the last lecture and
tell you about an exception which is
known as linkage because in tight and in
the in the abstract sense linkage is
simply when you have two traits that
tend to be inherited together
okay so just considering probability so
there you have traits inherited together
they're exhibiting what is known as
linkage okay but that's an abstract way
to think about it it's just based on
probability right so a physical model
for what linkage is is that you have
chromosomes the genes are on the
chromosomes and it for two genes to be
linked those genes are physically near
each other on the chromosome okay so the
physical model is that genes two genes
are near each other on the chromosome
okay so let's consider again these
generic genes a and B if a and B
resulting from this cross if these two
happen to be on the same chromosome now
they're physically coupled to each other
then they're gonna tend to be inherited
together right so they're always no
matter how those these align they're
always gonna go together during the
first meiotic division and that's just
going to only give you the parental
gametes okay so if there's linkage
you're gonna have let's let's consider
the case where you have complete linkage
if you have complete linkage a hundred
percent of the gametes are going to be
parentals and you're gonna have zero
percent non-parental okay that's if you
have that's if the genes are really
really really close to each other and
maybe you don't count so many progeny
you won't see any mixing between the two
okay but there's a phenomenon that can
separate these genes and it's known as
crossing over and another term to
describe it is recombination so the
alleles are getting recombined between
the chromosomes recombination and what
crossing over or recombination it is is
it's a mixing of the chromosomes if you
will or you could it's an exchange of
DNA so there's a physical exchange of
DNA from one of the homologous
chromosomes to the other okay so you can
think of this as an exchange of DNA
between the homologous chromosomes okay
and that's important it's not it's
exchange between the sister chromatids
but between the homologous chromosomes
that have the different alleles
okay and what's shown here is a
micrograph showing you a picture of the
process of crossing over you can see the
centromeres are the dark structures
there and you can see how the homologous
chromosomes intertwine and there are
regions where there looks like there's a
cross okay those are the homologous
chromosomes crossing over and exchanging
DNA such that one part of that
chromosome gets attached to the other
centromere okay
so I'll just show you in sort of my
silly cartoon form how this is just to
make it clear so let's say again you
have these a and B genes and they're
physically linked on the chromosome
during crossing over you can get an
exchange of these alleles such as a bit
of one chromosome goes to the other
homologous chromosome and vice versa
okay so now you have the dominant a
allele with the recessive B allele and
vice versa so now during meiosis one
after meiosis two this will give rise to
two types of gametes one of which is non
parental and the same the same for the
one down here you get two types of
gametes one is non parental the
lowercase a uppercase B gamete okay so
this happens if there's incomplete
linkage that means there can be a
recombination event that separates the
two genes and I'm going to give you an
an example of a case where data was
collected with what fraction of each
class there is so now we're considering
the example where you have a linkage so
that chromosome a and B are on the same
chromosome and so we'll consider a case
where in this class there are 165
members for this one there's 191 so I'm
coming
this and then for the first recombinant
class 23 individuals and for the last
there are 21 individuals okay so you can
see there are many more of the parental
class than the recombinant class but we
can calculate a frequency or
recombination frequency between these
two genes and in this case the
recombination frequency is 44 over 400
which is equal to 11 percent okay so 11
percent of the progeny from this cross
had some sort of crossing over between
the a and B alleles but it would have
been up here okay now this this this
frequency is interesting because it is
proportional to the distance that
separates these two genes okay so this
recombination frequency is proportional
to the linear distance between along the
chromosome between the genes
now it also depends on the recombination
frequency in a given organism or in a
given part part of the chromosome so
when you're comparing recombination
frequencies between different organisms
there's actually differences in the real
difference in the they're not equivalent
you can't compare them basically and
also there are regions of the chromosome
where recombination happens less
frequently than others and so again you
can't compare distances along those but
overall you can use this as a distance
in order to map genes along the linear
axis of a chromosome okay and maps are
useful because you can see where stuff
is right so in this example here so
highlight a couple places here's
Rivendell here's Lonely Mountain
here's Bay orange house so let's say we
are able to determine the distance
between Rivendell and Lonely Mountain
and the distance between Lonely Mountain
and valence house and the distance
between Rivendell and Bay or Ann's house
you'd be able to get a relative picture
of where all of these places are in
relation to each other okay so this is a
two dimensional map I'm showing here
it's not one dimensional but chromosomes
are one dimensional so it's a bit more
accurate okay so this this idea that
recombination frequency can be used to
measure distances between genes and that
this could be used to generate a map is
an idea that an undergraduate had while
working in Thomas Hunt Morgan slab back
in 1911 and what I find fascinating
about the story is this guy basically
blew off his homework to produce the
first genetic map in any organism okay
so the person who did it was Alfred
Sturtevant and he was an undergraduate
at Columbia working for Thomas Hunt
Morgan
and I'll just paraphrase this quote here
in 1911 he was talking with his advisor
Morgan and he realized that the
variations in the strength of linkage
attributed by Morgan to differences in
the separation of genes right so Morgan
had already made this connection that
the recombination frequency reflects the
distance between the genes but then
Sturdivant realized that this offered
the possibility of determining sequences
in the linear dimension of the
chromosome between the genes okay and so
then this is my favorite part I went
home and spent most of the night to the
neglect of my undergraduate homework and
producing the first chromosome map okay
and this is it
so the first chromosome map was of the
Drosophila X chromosome which we've been
talking about there's the white gene
which we've been talking about in the
context of eye color there's a yellow
body gene here there's vermilion
miniature rudimentary right these are
all visible phenotypes that you can see
in the fly and you can measure
recombination between various alleles of
these different genes all right so now I
want to go through with you an example
of how you can make one of these genetic
maps and it's essentially the same
conceptually as to what Sturdivant did
and it involves what is known as a
three-point cross so a three-point cross
okay so they're gonna be three genes all
of which are going to be hybrid and I'll
start with a parental generation that is
little a capital B capital D and we'll
cross this fly or organism to an
organism that is capital a lowercase B
lowercase D okay yes
Harmon
so what I'm writing here is the
phenotype basically and so these are
homozygous for each of these yes mm-hmm
so we're starting I could also write
this as but I'm not going to draw the
chromosomes because it's it kind of gets
gets more confusing I'll just draw I'll
draw the chromosomes here in the f1
because we haven't now basically a tri
hybrid with run one chromosome that
looks like this right they got that
chromosome from this individual here and
another chromosome will look like this
okay see so so this f1 of fly is
heterozygous for these three genes and
it has these two parental chromosomes
okay so now we can look at the gametes
that result from this fly by doing a
test cross just like we did before and
so we want to cross this to a fly that's
homozygous recessive for each of these
genes and now we can look at the progeny
and just by looking at the phenotype
we're gonna know the genotype because we
know all of the flies and from this
cross have a chromosome from this
individual that has recessive alleles
for each gene so we can consider now
this first one here that's one potential
class of progeny another class would be
this one and these two you can see
resemble the parents right so these are
the parental classes of the progeny so
this is parental
all right now you can consider all other
combinations of alleles and so I'll just
go I'll quickly write them down you
could have something progeny that looked
like this and this these are just kind
of reciprocal from each other
you could have progeny that look like
this and this and the last class would
be this and this okay so all of these
progeny that I drew down here are
recombinant because they don't resemble
the parents right because there are
three genes now there's many more ways
to get recombinant progeny as opposed to
having just two genes right so you can
have many different combinations of
these different alleles and so now I'm
gonna give you data from across with
three such genes so you might get 580
individuals that look like this 592 like
this 45 and 48 e 994 three and five okay
so this is data that is I believe from
fly genes
I've just ignored the fly nomenclature
because it's confusing and just like
giving them lettered names okay but this
reflects data from some cross somewhere
okay so now we want to know let's go
back to our map we want to make a map
okay and so to make our map we're gonna
want to consider all pairwise different
distances between different genes okay
so we'll start with the a and B gene
right over here so let's consider the a
B distance and remember to get a
distance we're looking at the number of
the frequency which there is
recombination between these two genes
okay so we now have to look through
all of these recombinant class of
progeny and figure out the ones that
have had a recombination between a and B
right so on the parent chromosome you
see little lowercase a started out with
capital B okay
and vice versa okay so any case where we
don't have lowercase a paired with
capital B there's been some type of
exchange okay so here lowercase a is
with lowercase B so that's a recombinant
here uppercase a is with uppercase B
that's been that's a recombinant too so
we have to add all these up so 45 plus
40 how about here recombination here or
no yes I'm hearing yes that's correct
here recombination yes or no I'm Karmen
shaking her head no she's exactly right
so we just have to these are all the
recombinants between a and B so it's 45
plus 40 plus 89 plus 94 which equals 268
over a total progeny of 14 huh
48 and that gives you a map distance of
18.5% because this method was developed
in Morgan's lab this measurement is also
known as a centimorgan it was named in
honor of Morgan so that's what I refer
to and I have lowercase T capital M
that's a centimorgan so you can also use
centimorgan here alright so that's a and
B but now we have to consider other
distances so how about the ad distance
and again we have to go through and
figure out where the alleles for a and D
have been recombined okay so little a is
with big with capital D and uppercase a
is with lowercase D so we have to find
all the cases where that's not the case
here this is lowercase a with capital D
and capital A with lowercase D
this is parental from the respect of
just the a and D genes but all the rest
of these guys are recombinant okay so
this is 89 plus ninety four plus three
plus five which comes out to be one
hundred ninety one over one thousand
four hundred forty eight and this is
thirteen point two centimorgans so
that's the distance between a and D okay
distance between a be distance between a
D so the last combination then is just B
and D so if we consider the B D distance
again we have to look for all cases in
which lowercase B and D become separated
an uppercase B and D become separated
here they're separated here they're
separated wait no not here sorry here
they're not separated here they are
separated say everyone see how I'm doing
this are there any questions about it
you can just shout it out if you have a
question so this distance is six point
four centimorgans okay everyone see how
I'm considering every pairwise
combination of genes and then just
ignoring the other one and looking for
where there's been a recombination in
the progeny okay so now that we have our
distances we can we can make our map
right so the two genes that are farthest
apart are a and B okay so that's kind of
like here Rivendell and lonely mountain
okay those are the two genes that are at
the extremities okay so I'll draw this
out we'll put it doesn't matter which
way you put it
we're just mapping these genes relative
to each other but B and a are the
farthest apart from each other
now if we consider the distance between
B and D that's six point four centimeter
Morgan's so it appears that D is closer
to be than it is to a because it's
thirteen centimorgans away from a okay
so D is kind of like Bayern's house here
it's closer to Rivendell than it is from
Lonely Mountain so we'll put that in
there
this distance is six point four
centimorgans and then the distance here
is thirteen point two centimorgans okay
as far as I know no one in the field of
genetic mapping has been assaulted by
large spiders but the field is still
young so one thing that should be maybe
bothering you right now is if you add up
the distance between B and D and D and a
you don't in fact get eighteen point
four centimorgans instead you get
nineteen point six centimorgans this is
nineteen point six sentence okay so it
seems like somehow we are under
estimating this distance here okay so we
seem to be under estimating this so why
is it that we are under estimating this
distance well for to consider that you
have to sort of look at what how all of
these classes were generated okay so now
I'm going to go through each class and
we'll look at how it was generated I'm
also going to well just draw new
chromosomes so we have to draw this
order now we have BD a so the first
chromosome is B D a that's right
BD a the other chromosome is B D
eh okay so now we look and see how this
recombinant class was generated okay so
this is lowercase a well start with B
lowercase B lowercase a but capital D ok
so it's capital D lowercase a so that
recombinant results from this chromosome
here where there's crossing over and
little B gets hooked up to Big D in
little a okay see how I did that and
then if we consider this class this is
uppercase B lowercase D capital A okay
so these two classes of progeny result
from a single crossover between B and D
okay so this is a single crossover
between B and D genes and now we can go
through and look at how this is
generated so to get all recessive
alleles on the same chromosome there
would be a cross over here and so this
is a single crossover between DNA so a
single crossover between DNA now this
last these last couple classes of
progeny are interesting and that they're
the least frequent class and so when we
consider how they're generated we'll
start with uppercase B let's see if I
can get rid of this so uppercase B
lowercase D lowercase a okay and so what
this last class is is actually a double
crossover okay so this is a double
crossover and it's least frequent
because it's there's a lower probability
of getting two crossovers in this region
but now you see that even though it
doesn't look like there was
recombination between a and D
in fact there was there were two
crossovers and it just looks like there
was no recombination if you didn't see
the behavior of gene gene D ok so if we
take into account that there are
actually double crossovers between B and
a then if we add that into our
calculation here where you add in 3 plus
5 x 2 because as a double cross oh these
are both double crossover events then
you get the 19.6 sentiments that you
would expect by adding up the other
recombinations okay how is that is that
clear to everybody
you're gonna have to make maps like this
on the problem set and possibly the test
so make sure you can given yeah or e
[Music]
it's because when you have two genes
that are very far apart you can have
multiple crossovers and when you have
sort of crossovers that are in pairs of
two then you're not it's going to go
from one sand back to the other and so
you're not going to see recombination
between the two alleles so it's it's an
underestimate because if you have
multiples of 2 in terms of crossovers
you're gonna miss the recombination
events do you see what I mean
you understand that you can miss the
double crossover events yeah right so
then you're gonna underestimate the
number of crossovers that actually
happened in that genetic region mm-hmm
all right now I want to end with an
experiment that again makes the point
that that genes are these entities that
are on chromosomes and so just like you
can have linkage between two genes on
the same chromosome you can also have
linkage between genes and physical
structures on chromosomes like the
centromere okay so you could have genes
like a and B here that are present on
the chromosomes and present very near
the centromere of those chromosomes okay
so they could be right on top of the
centromere okay and to show you how this
manifests itself I have to tell you
about another organism which is a
unicellular organism called yeast and
yeast is special in that it can exist in
both a haploid and a diploid form so it
has a life cycle that involves this
going both as a haploid and as a diploid
and so you can take yeast and we'll take
two haploid yeast cells and much like
gametes these confuse to form a zygote
so in this case I'm taking again we'll
consider two generic genes a and B and
we'll make a diploid D cell that is
heterozygous or hybrid for a and B and
what's great and special about yeast and
why I'm telling you about this is
because as opposed to flies and us and
other organisms the product of a single
meiosis is packaged in like this single
package if you will so the yeast can
undergo meiosis and the product of a
single meiosis is present in this case
where each of these would represent a
haploid cell that then can divide and
make many cells but this is the product
of a single meiosis in a package okay so
you can actually see the direct like
result of a mitotic division a single
mitotic division so this is the product
of single mitotic division okay and that
specialty is when when we make gametes
right we have individual cells all the
products of meiosis are split up and
then just one randomly finds an egg and
fertilize it so you don't know which of
the gametes are from the product of a
single meiosis okay and so being able to
see the product of a single meiosis
allows us to see things like genes being
linked to physical structures on the
chromosome like the centromere okay so
if we consider this case these two genes
are both linked to the centromere and
during metaphase of meiosis one they
could align like this in which case you
would get spores that are parental
parental for both dominant alleles or
parental for both recessive alleles okay
so each of these cells is known as a
spore so I'll label spore numbers here
so this is spore number and in this case
you get 1 2 spores that are dominant for
both alleles and 2 spores that are
recessive for both alleles and this is
known because there are two types is
known as a die type and this is a
parental die type because you have two
types of spores and they are both
parental
okay an alternative scenario is that
these chromosomes would align
differently right so you get parental
spore is there however and alternatively
you could have this configuration where
this is now flipped and during meiosis
one here these chromosomes move together
and they again produce two types of
spores so it's a die type but in this
case all the spores are non-parental
okay so another scenario is you get this
and because there are two types and
they're non parental this is known as
non parental die type okay so that's a
non parental die type okay
and if if these genes are linked to the
centromere completely then you can only
get these two classes of packages okay
so these genes are unlinked so the two
genes are unlinked but both linked to
the centromere then you get parental die
type 50% parental die type 50% non
parental died type so I'm abbreviating
parental die Tate parental die type PD
and non parental die type NPD okay so
what has to happen to get another type
of spore and another type of spore would
be you could have spores that are all
different genotypes from each other and
that you have a cap dominant a be
dominant a recessive be recessive a
dominant B and lowercase am
okay and this is known as tetra type
because there are four types so how do
you get this tetra type anyone have an
idea yeah Jeremy
where would the crossing-over happen
but between between Deal Leal and what
the crossing over would occur between
the the gene and the centromere exactly
Jeremy is exactly right so Jeremy said
that in order to get a tetra type you
have to have a recombination event but
this time not between two genes but
between a gene and the centromere so
they have to at least one of the genes
has to be unlinked to the centromere
okay and in that case now you get you
get a mitotic event that gives gives
rise to four spores and there are four
different ways to get this so if you
have two genes unlinked and at least one
is unlinked to the centromere then you
get a pattern where you have a 1 to 1 to
4 ratio between all these different
events so you have a 1 to 1 to 4 ratio
between parental die type non parental
die type and tetra type okay and we can
see this in yeast if you have two genes
that are linked to the centromere you
only get parental die types and non
parental die types where virtually
everything else gives rise to tetra
types except if they're linked what
happens if the two genes are linked to
each other
irregardless of the centromere if you
have two genes that are linked what's
gonna be what are your progeny you gonna
look like
you're only gonna get the parentals or
you're gonna get a lot of parentals
Xavier is exactly right
right if the two genes are linked the
parental die tapes are going to be much
greater than any of the other classes
okay now this might seem ISO Tarek but I
like the idea that you can have linkage
between a gene and something that's like
just the place on the chromosome that's
getting physically pulled it all makes
it much more physical which I I think is
nice to think about all right we're
almost done I just have yes Natalie
yes so PD is parental die type so this
is the parental die type it's a class of
product here where you get four spores
that are each of these genotypes okay so
each of these one two three and four
would represent one of these cells from
a single mitotic event does that make
sense Natalie okay does it does everyone
see what I did there okay so these 1 2 &
3 are the spores of the mud the mitotic
event right here
you